As with most legal matters, answering the
question of what exactly happens when a person
is accidentally declared dead varies from
country to country, although, curiously, from
our research, with some exceptions like a
few instances we found in Canada particularly,
it seems as if the United States is one of
the few countries where the aftermath of this
can be long term devastating to the unlucky
individual, even after they get declared alive
again.
But to start with, how exactly does one actually
get accidentally declared dead in the first
place?
It turns out in pretty much every nation,
most of the time simply via clerical error.
In modern times, this usually just means a
typo or the like.
So, yes, particularly for you U.S. citizens
reading this, just go ahead and think about
that your life could be ruined, or at least
a good portion of it, by a simple typo made
by some random person at any given moment…
On that note, although exact figures are hard
to come by, it’s estimated by the Social
Security Administration that in the US some
seven to fourteen thousand people are accidentally
declared dead each year.
Numbers from other nations were seemingly
impossible to come by, but we did at least
dig out that in Canada from 2007-2013 they
had approximately 5500 people accidentally
declared dead, or an average of about 900
people per year.
Given that the United States has approximately
nine times as many people as Canada, this
would put the equivalent number at about 8,000
people per year, so right inline with the
low end estimate of the United States’ numbers.
Alright, so a misplaced finger by some worker
at a funeral home, hospital, etc. has now
accidentally killed you as far as the government
is concerned.
How do you fix it?
It turns out correcting such a mistake pretty
much everywhere we looked at, in theory, is
as simple as walking into the appropriate
government office and letting the fact that
you just walked into a government office speak
for itself, after of course you provide sufficient
identification to prove you are who you say
you are.
For example, in the United States you just
need to visit your local Social Security Administration
office with one piece of appropriate picture
ID, such as a driver’s license, passport,
etc. and inform them of the mistake in their
records.
And, indeed, in reports of this happening
to people in several different nations we
looked at, this seems to more or less clear
the matter up within a few weeks at most.
Certainly this few weeks can be a bit traumatizing
and make things difficult in a variety of
ways, as we’ll get into, but it’s more
of a blip, outside of some isolated reports
from Canada, where for some people the ordeal
dragged on for months, and some not so isolated
reports from the U.S.
In fact, the most outrageous report we could
find from Sweden, for example, simply noted
that the 47 year old Swedish woman was inconvenienced
by having to spend several hours unblocking
various accounts after the government agency
dutifully apologized for the mistake and had
it corrected in their system.
For her trouble, she was awarded 20,500 kronors
(about $2,200).
Then there’s the United States… owing
to a quirk of the way the Death Master file
works and the way various entities use it,
as well as previous to a few years ago the
fact that this file was available to anyone
who wanted to buy it, let’s just say things
are a bit more complicated, even though getting
declared alive again is actually relatively
straightforward as described.
But before we go any further, we should probably
talk about what this Death Master file actually
is.
Various nations have their own ways of tracking
this and rules and regulations governing such
a dataset, but it mostly just comes down to
a file maintained by some branch of the government
that gets names added to it via reports from
various groups or people about a death.
In Britain, for instance, a name can be added
by anyone simply by going to the appropriate
government website and noting a death, as
well as providing appropriate proof of death,
such as a copy of a death certificate.
Other sources that don’t necessarily have
to include proof of death include reports
from places like funeral homes, hospitals,
and other such institutions.
As you can imagine from all this, there is
more than a little room for accidental error
here, given the wide variety of sources this
information is being collated from, and with
little in the way of verification occurring
as to the accuracy of everything coming in.
In essence, these types of systems are fairly
rife for an occasional typo to pop up and
for no one to notice until the accidentally
declared dead person themselves find out,
often in traumatic fashion.
This all brings us around to the United States’
Social Security Administration Death Master
file.
It turns out this was never meant to be used
as a definitive record for deaths.
It was originally put in place in 1936 as
a way for the Social Security Administration
to help make sure they weren’t paying out
benefits to people no longer alive and for
other use internally.
In fact, the Social Security Administration
explicitly notes that this data should NOT
be used as a definitive record of who is alive
or dead in the United States.
As the Inspector General of the Social Security
Administration in 2015, Patrick P. O’Carroll,
Jr., stated before Congress, “SSA does not
receive death information for all individuals,
thus SSA does not guarantee the [Death Master
File’s] completeness.”
Nevertheless, as with the Social Security
number itself, this eventually got coopted
by various groups who needed a reasonably
accurate dataset of who was alive and who
was not.
This all brings us around to why being accidentally
declared dead can be so devastating to an
individual.
It turns out that this data is used by many
companies, most pertinent to the topic at
hand being financial institutions and agencies
doling out various benefits, like retirement
and the like.
Once the death database is updated, this information
percolates out to all of these institutions
automatically.
And then, even worse, from there percolates
out to other institutions who don’t use
the Death Master file directly, but buy or
share information from institutions that do.
So, to begin with, upon “death” all government
benefits you may have been entitled to from
Social Security to a government pension will
be stopped.
While this may or may not be an immediate
problem for a given person, it turns out that
as soon as you’re declared dead, it’s
entirely possible that your bank accounts,
credit cards, and the like will get frozen
and any attempts to retrieve money from them
by you will be flagged as fraud.
Depending on the institution, there may or
may not be issues accessing any joint account
you hold as well.
On top of this, upon notification of the passing,
everyone you owe money to will suddenly be
able to claim that money from your estate,
and even potentially do so when their systems
find out you’re dead… because apparently
even being dead isn’t a good enough excuse
to stop paying back your student loans.
On the plus side, if you’re married at the
time you’re accidentally declared dead,
your spouse or whoever you named as a beneficiary
on such a plan will be eligible to claim any
life insurance policy you have in place.
Unfortunately, this is money they will later
be expected to pay back once you’re proved
to be alive.
So not a great perk.
Being dead, of course, you can also expect
that you may end up losing your job as it’s
kind of hard to employ a dead person officially,
turns out.
On that note, you’ll also find it exceptionally
difficult to find work during your time as
a legally dead person.
At best, you’ll have to work for cash under
the table.
And it’s important to note in all of this,
it’s not uncommon at all for you to be suspected
of identity theft and possibly even get arrested,
which will also come with its own host of
problems when the police try to enter your
details into their system to process you.
Speaking of being arrested for stealing your
own identity, from 1980 to 2013 thanks to
a Freedom of Information Act lawsuit, the
Death Master File in the U.S. was publicly
accessible to anyone who wanted to pay the
fee to the Department of Commerce’s National
Technical Information Service (NTIS).
This file includes the person’s name, date
of birth, date of death, social security number,
whether death is verified or a death certificate
documented, and, up until 2011, also included
the last known zip code, and zip code where
any death benefit was sent.
This made it all ridiculously easy for actual
identify thieves to work their magic and try
to get away with all sorts of shenanigans
in your name, with the immediate few week
window directly after you’re declared dead
being highly targeted as not every system,
and maybe not even you yourself, at this point
may be aware you’ve been declared dead.
Thus, if you were one of those unlucky individuals,
when you once again get declared alive again,
officially, you then got the reward of having
to deal with whatever the identify thief managed
to do with your good name while you were dead.
Today, in an attempt to stop the identify
theft problem for the dead or accidentally
declared dead, only approved institutions
have immediate access to the current Death
Master file, with a three year waiting period
before the wider public’s copy of the file
will show a given person’s death, though
for various other reasons identify theft of
the recently deceased is still a major problem.
This brings us around to another systemic
problem with the way the system works in the
U.S.- the way the file is updated, or not
in some cases.
The version of the Death Master File that
is downloadable is updated weekly, but only
the last six revisions can be downloaded directly
and if you want to go any further back than
that for the full list, you have to order
a copy loaded onto a CD.
The problem here is that if the institution
updates irregularly, they might completely
miss the revision that you were actually declared
alive again, with this marked in the file
with a “D” indicating your record should
be deleted from any copies of the database
stored by these various institutions.
Miss that revision and your name will remain
in these systems’ databases.
On top of that, many institutions that don’t
use the Death Master File do buy and share
such information from other institutions,
who may for a time have the erroneous information.
Thus, it may simply be up to you in all these
types of cases to prove to them you’re once
again alive, officially.
And, again, do expect when you’re doing
so that they’ll suspect you of being an
identify thief because of how relatively common
identity theft of the dead is.
Also, even if you do manage to convince the
world you’re alive, there’s always the
chance that someone, somewhere will get their
hands on an outdated version of the Death
Master File and accidentally kill you again
in whatever system they use, which in turn
might get shared around even further, even
potentially to institutions you already proved
you were alive to, but now may have to do
it again.
For some people who’ve had this happen,
they note it can be like a game of Wac-o-mole
for sometimes several years later.
To be fair, it’s noted that, much like in
most countries we looked at, once you’ve
satisfactory proven to the Social Security
Administration you’re indeed still alive,
it generally takes only a few weeks at most
to fix in their database, though there are
exceptions where it sometimes takes a lot
longer.
Further, the Social Security Administration
will then issue you with an “erroneous death
case — third party contact” which you
can use as proof of you not actually being
dead and not being an identify thief when
dealing with banks, hospitals or any other
service or person that currently believes
you’re not alive.
Sometimes even this isn’t enough though
and some financial institution especially
are still noted as being difficult to convince
that you’re not a zombie- again, real identify
thieves are rather good at forging things,
leading some institutions to be skeptical.
If this happens, you’re advised to contact
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau to
speak to the institution on your behalf.
Alternatively, you can always contact your
“local congressional representative‘s
constituent services office” if you want
to circumvent all the red tape and have the
problem addressed directly, though your mileage
may vary with this particular avenue.
As for how long it take to correct the mistake
in the U.S., there’s no definitive answer
but, again, there are documented cases of
people fighting with various institutions
for years to prove they’re alive and there
are examples of people dying in real life
before they were able to fully correct the
mistake.
A notable case is that of Judy Rivers who
spent seven years dealing with the ramifications
of being accidentally declared dead, during
which this woman who formerly had over $80,000
in her bank account alone, along with a rather
good career at the time, upon being declared
dead became financially destitute, lost her
job and house, among other things.
In her own words to the Senate Committee on
Homeland Security and Governmental Affairs
who were looking into ways in which the system
might be fixed:
I could never have imagined I would reach
the point of hopelessness, homelessness, loss
of reputation and credibility, unable to obtain
a job, an apartment, a student loan, or even
a cell phone.
Suspected as an identity thief by nearly every
apartment manager or Human Resource Director
I encountered became a way of life.
Each time I got into my car I was panic stricken
that the police would stop me and I would
have to try and prove my identity.
Another example is that of retired army drill
sergeant Jerry Miller who was accidentally
declared dead four times, each time resulting
in him having his veteran’s benefits and
government pension stopped.
And, no, he wasn’t the random victim of
an unfortunate typo four times in a row to
the Social Security Administration.
That just happened once.
His case was one of those where an old copy
of the Death Master File was being passed
around and simply just kept getting him declared
dead again by the U.S. Department of Veterans
Affairs.
Each time he’d prove he was still alive
and it would be fine for a while, until he’d
once again find himself declared dead by them.
Miller almost lost his house, suffered failing
health when he was unable to get needed prescriptions
and received a letter asking him to pay back
around $94,000 dollars worth of benefit cheques
he’d supposedly fraudulently cashed while
previously being “dead”.
Of course, he was very much alive and entitled
to those cheques but was now in a bit of legal
hot water over the matter.
Perhaps the most bizarre story of all though
is that of Donald Miller Jr whose request
to be declared legally alive was turned down
by a judge.
This one was not, however, a case of a typo,
but rather a case of a disappearance.
In a nutshell, Miller disappeared from his
Ohio home sometime in 1994.
After an investigation, Miller was declared
dead in absentia, his life insurance policy
was paid out and his Social Security number
retired.
In 2005 Miller resurfaced and revealed that
he’d fled because he owed around $26,000
in child support to his ex-wife that he couldn’t
afford.
Unaware he’d “died”, Miller tried to
have the decision overturned so that he could
get a driver’s license after having got
his life back together only to have the decision
challenged by his ex-wife.
It would later turn out that Miller’s ex-wife
couldn’t afford to pay back the life insurance
settlement she’d received as a result of
his death and that him staying “dead”
would allow her to avoid doing so.
When the case got to court, because of various
quirks of the law, a judge was forced to rule
that Miller had left it too long to challenge
the decision, despite his contention that
he didn’t know he’d died.
So, yes, the judge in this case, knowing Miller
was who he claimed to be and was literally
standing in front of him, declared him legally
dead anyway.
So yeah, in short, if you live anywhere and
are accidentally declared dead by your government,
expect the next month or two to be a bit of
a living hell, but as far as we can find,
this usually gets cleared up pretty quickly,
with exceptions.
But if you live in the United States, just
because of some quirks about how the system
works there, as one Liz Weston of the Denver
Post aptly noted, “If the Social Security
Administration thinks you’re dead, you might
wish you were.”